you have to understand in 1916 there was
a book that was written
and it was written by a young man by the
name of Madison Grant
and he went to I think he went to
Columbia Law School
and he's in New York he's upset the book
is called the passing of the great race
keep America white and pure this is the
book he writes 1916.
and he was upset
about the immigration into America in
particular through New York which is
where he was
upset about the Jews coming in from
Europe the whole nine yards and he's
just like shut it down
and this book
takes off
this book becomes
like it really takes off oh it starts
changing laws the whole nine yards
and
this young man read this book
and another this young man a young man
read this book and said this is the
greatest book I've ever read this book
is my Bible
and that young man in 1916 was Adolf
Hitler
so Adolf Hitler reads this book
and he's like this is the blueprint
so not only did we create
this racism and anti-semitism
we exported it all the way to Europe and
inspired and inspired all the way to
Europe and it came back as the Holocaust
so Adolf Hitler
gave an interview to the New York Times
and Adolf Hitler said hey I do not
understand why
America is giving me such pushback
because everything I've learned about
immigration control I've learned from
America
Adolf Hitler actually said
I thought America would become my
partner
wow
that's unbelievable so this is why
Adolf Hitler sent his Nazi lawyers
to America and said study the Jim Crow
laws
that they're using on the Negroes
and come back and use them on the Jews
studied everything we did
to create his evil Acts
he got the blueprint from us
[Music]